right here we have the graph of y is
equal to 250 over 25 plus x squared and
what I'm curious about in this video
is the total area under this curve and
above the x-axis so I'm talking about
everything everything that I am shading
in white here including what we can't
see to those we keep moving to the right
and we keep moving to the left so I'm
talking about from X goes from from X at
negative infinity all the way to X at
infinity so first how would we actually
denote this well it would be an improper
integral we would denote this area as
the indefinite integral from X is equal
to negative infinity to X is equal to
infinity of our function 250 over 25
plus 25 plus x squared DX now we've
already seen improper integrals where
one of our boundaries with infinity but
how do you do it when you have one
boundary at positive infinity and one
boundary at negative infinity you can't
take a limit to two different things and
so the way that we're going to tackle
this is to actually break up this area
into two different improper integrals
one improper integral that describes
this area right over here in blue from
negative infinity to zero so we'll say
this is equal to the improper integral
that goes from negative infinity to zero
of 250 over 25 plus x squared DX plus
the improper integral that goes from 0
to positive infinity so plus the
improper or the definite integral from 0
to positive infinity of 250 over over 25
plus x squared 25 plus x squared DX
and now we can start to make sense of
this so what we have in blue what we
have in blue can be rewritten this is
equal to the limit as n approaches
negative infinity of the definite
integral from n to 0 of 250 over 25 plus
x squared DX plus plus and I'm running
out of real estate here plus the limit
as it's already used
let me use em now the limit as M
approaches positive infinity of the
definite integral from 0 to M of 250
over 25 plus x squared DX so now all we
have to do is evaluate these definite
integrals and to do that we just have to
figure out an antiderivative of 250 over
25 plus x squared so let's try to figure
out what that is so an anti-ager I'll do
it over here on the left so the
antiderivative where you need to figure
out the antiderivative of 250 over 25
plus x squared and it might already jump
out at you that trig substitution might
be a good thing to do you see this
pattern of a squared plus x squared
where in this case a would be 5 so we
can make the substitution that X is
equal to a tangent theta 5 tangent theta
and since we're going to have to reverse
substitute later on we can also put in
the constraint well we say x over 5 is
equal to tangent of theta which is
completely consistent with this first
statement and so if we wanted to have
data expressed as a function of X and we
can put the constraint that theta is
equal to arctangent arctangent of X over
5 so once again this is completely
consistent with this over here X can be
5 tangent of theta and theta can be 5 it
can be equal to arctangent of x over 5
so now let's do the substitution
actually before that we also have to
figure out what DX is equal to so DX DX
is equal to I'll do it right over here
DX well the derivative of this with
respect to theta is 5 secant squared
theta D theta so now we're ready to
substitute back in so all of this
business is going to be equal to is
going to be equal to 250 times DX
well 250 times DX is 250 times 5 secant
squared theta D theta so that's 250 DX
is this business up here all of that
over 25 plus x squared well x squared is
going to be 25
five tan square root of theta 25 tangent
squared of theta and now we can try to
simplify all of this business this is
equal to let's see this is equal to 250
times five secant squared theta over
twenty five times one plus tangent
squared theta D theta so 25 goes into
250 ten times and then one plus tangent
squared theta is secant squared theta
you can prove it for yourself if you
rights tan squared theta as sine squared
theta over cosine squared theta add that
to 1 which is the same thing as cosine
squared theta over cosine squared theta
and then you can use some basic basic
trig identities to realize that this
this is equal to secant squared theta
which simplifies our expression a good
bit you get secant squared theta over
secant squared theta which is just 1 and
so you're just left with the 10 times
the 550d theta so this is equal to 50
I'll take the 50 outside the integral 50
D theta which is equal to 50 theta 50
theta we can write the plus C just to
show that this these are all of the
antiderivatives but we only need kind of
the most basic antiderivative to
evaluate these definite integrals but we
right now only have it in terms of theta
let's write this in terms of X we set
the constraint that theta is equal to
arctangent of x over 5 so this is equal
to 50 arctangent arc tangent of x over 5
plus C these are all the anti
derivatives we can pick C is equal to 0
to find n antiderivative of these things
to evaluate the definite integrals so
let's do that so what we have in blue we
can rewrite we can rewrite as the limit
as n approaches negative infinity of of
the antiderivative of this or an
antiderivative of this which we could
say is 50 arctangent arc tangent of x
over 5 and we're going to evaluate it at
0 and N and to this we're going to add
the limit as
M approaches positive infinity of 50
just antiderivative this 50 arctangent
not act tangent arc tangent arc tangent
of x over 5 evaluated from 0 to M from 0
from 0 to M and let me put a little
parentheses right around this x over 5
so what's this going to be this is going
to be 50 so let me write it it's going
to be the limit as n approaches negative
infinity of 50 arc tangent of 0 over 5
minus 50 arc arc tangent of n n over 5
and then to that we're going to add to
that we're going to add them give myself
even a little bit more space the limit
limit as M approaches infinity of 50 arc
tan arc tan of M over 5 minus 50 arc 10
I see where I think you see where all
this is going minus 50 arc tan of 0 over
5 so now we can evaluate these things
and to help us evaluate them let's think
about a unit circle so let's think about
a unit circle so it can really visualize
the arctangent function so the tangent
one way to think about the tangent is
the slope of the line that is on the
angle or that helps define the terminal
side of an angle so for example if we
have an angle that looks like this this
is an angle between the positive x-axis
and this line right over here if we have
an angle just like that the tangent of
that angle is going to be the slope of
this line and so one way to think about
it is okay if I'm thinking about if I if
I want the arc tangent of 0 it's
essentially saying okay let's get a line
where the term or an angle where the
terminal side has slope 0 well an angle
where the terminal side has slope 0 is
an angle of 0 so arc tangent of 0 is 0
radians so this 50 times 0 that's just
going to be 0
now we could also write that over here
this is just going to be zero so what
we're left with what we're left with is
the limit the limit as n approaches
negative infinity of negative 50
arctangent arc tangent of n over 5 plus
plus the limit as M approaches positive
infinity of 50 arctangent arctangent of
M over 5 so let's think about what these
are going to be so the limit as n
approaches negative infinity one way to
view that is the limit as the slope of
this terminal side approaches negative
infinity so that's getting more and more
negative more and more negative it
approaches it's that negative in finger
it's approaching negative infinity
negative infinity when our angle when
our angle right over here is negative PI
over 2 radians negative PI over 2
radians so arc tan of or you could say
the limit of the limit of arc tan of n
over 5 as n approaches negative infinity
this part right over here is going to
approach as n approaches negative
infinity it's going to be negative PI
over 2 and then we're just going to
multiply that times the negative 50 so
this is going to be negative 50 times
negative PI over 2 negative PI over 2
which is going to be positive 25 pi so
this is going to be 25 pi and similarly
our 10 of M over 5 is M approaches
infinity well as m approaches infinity
the slope of the terminal side of the
angle approaches infinity so the slope
is getting higher higher it approaches
infinity as it gets more close to closer
and closer to vertical so the arc tan of
M over 5 is M approaches infinity is
going to be positive PI over 2 this is
an angle of positive PI over 2 so we see
an orange right over here it's going to
be positive 50 times pi over 2 which is
going to be 25 pi so the area that we
have in blue going back to our original
problem the area that we have in blue is
25 pi
the area that we have in orange is 25 pi
and so if we wanted to answer our
original question what's the total area
under this curve which is kind of a cool
and a cool question to try to answer we
get it's 25 pi put plus 25 pi which is
50 50 pi and we're done